♪ ♪
>> Greg: A NEW POLL ON THE
RELIABILITY OF JOURNALISTS COMES
FROM PUGH WHICH MAKES SENSE
BECAUSE IT STINKS FOR THE PRESS.
LESS THAN HALF OF AMERICANS HAVE
A GREAT DEAL OF CONFIDENCE IN
THEM.
I WONDER WHY.
SPEAK AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
END OF THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
>> HE’S GOT TO KNOW THAT HIS
FUTURE LOOKS LIKE IT’S BEHIND
BARS.
>> IT’S CLEAR THAT MUELLER IS
CONNECTING THE DOTS BETWEEN A
MASSIVE OBSTRUCTION INTENDED TO
HIDE THE TRUTH.
>> THIS CLOUD WILL HANG OVER
HIM.
>> THE PRESIDENT SEES THE WALLS
CLOSING IN.
>> THE PRESIDENT C IS
EFFECTIVELY A RUSSIAN OP.
>> Greg: THAT IS A MONTAGE.
AMERICANS RANKED THE PRESS
BEHIND LAWYERS AND ABOUT ELECTED
OFFICIALS, IT’S LIKE SAYING THAT
YOU ARE WORSE THAN VERMIN BUT
NOT AS BAD AS LICE.
SORRY, EMILY.
BUT THE NUMBERS WOULD’VE BEEN
WORSE WERE NOT FOR FOX NEWS.
THE REASON, WE ARE AWESOME WHICH
IS WHY THE OTHER GUYS HATE US SO
MUCH.
IT SEEMS LIKE OTHER CABLE
NETWORKS EXIST JUST TO WATCH FOX
FOX.
>> FOX NEWS.
>> THIS IS WHAT FOX IS ABOUT.
>> FIGURES ON FOX NEWS.
>> FOX NEWS.
>> WATCHING FOX.
>> Greg: MY GOD, WHAT IF WE
STOP WORKING?
CNN WOULD HAVE TO COVER NEWS.
WHO COULD THEY BLAME EVERYTHING
ON, RIGHT, CHRIS?
>> EVERYONE AROUND THEM HAS A
MAN’S GONE.
HE DOESN’T BECAUSE HE WANTS TO
KEEP UP THE FOX FARCE, THIS B.S.
THAT COVID-19 IS OVERRATED.
I GUESS THE ANTIELITISTS OVER
THERE ARE OKAY WITH 10,000 MORE
DEATHS.
>> Greg: WHAT A CHILD.
THIS GUY HAS THE GALL TO BLAME
US FOR FUTURE DEATHS.
WHAT ABOUT DEATH THAT ALREADY
HAPPENED?
THE ACTUAL THOUSANDS IN
RESTROOMS HE FAILED TO ASK
HASBRO ABOUT BECAUSE HE HAD
OTHER THINGS ON HIS MIND.
>> DO YOU THINK YOU ARE AN
ATTRACTIVE PERSONNEL BECAUSE YOU
ARE SINGLE AND READY TO MINGLE?
DO YOU REALLY THINK YOU’RE SOME
DESIRABLE SINGLE PERSON?
AT THIS ISN’T JUST PEOPLE’S PAIN
COMING OUT OF THEM?
>> I THINK BEAUTY IS IN THE EYE
OF THE BEHOLDER.
>> Greg: AND 5200 PEOPLE DIED
IN REST HOMES.
THE POLLS SUGGEST THE MEDIA
DOESN’T ACT ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC PROBABLY BECAUSE THEY
HATE THE PUBLIC.
THE PREZ IS OVEREDUCATED,
CLOISTERED, FAR REMOVED FROM
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY MAKE THINGS,
THE IDEA OF SLUMMING IT IS
NONORGANIC QUINOA.
I WONDER IF THE MEDIA BECAME
TRULY DIVERSE ESPECIALLY IN
PERSPECTIVE, WITH THEY HAVE
GOTTEN SO MUCH WRONG?
WITH A LIST TRUMP’S VICTORY OR
SEEN THROUGH THE OCCLUSION AND
OBSTRUCTION HOSTS, THE
IMPEACHMENT TRAVESTY, WITH A
HAVE SEEN THE CORONAVIRUS COMING
INSTEAD OF DROOLING OVER
ADAM SCHIFF’S ALLIES?
WHERE THEY’VE SEEN MICHAEL FLYNN
FOR WHAT HE WAS, A HERO GETTING
SCREWED.
THE FACT IS WE KNOW THE MEDIA IS
BROKEN.
THE ONLY ENTITY NOT REPORTING IT
IS THE MEDIA.
WE NEED A 12-STEP PROGRAM FOR
THE PRESS.
THE FIRST ONE WOULD BE TO BUY
THEM A MIRROR.
EMILY, WHAT’S YOUR TAKE ON THE
POLL?
EMILY?
>> Emily: SORRY.
I’M SORRY, I DIDN’T HEAR THAT.
SOMEONE WAS IN MY EAR.
WHAT WAS THE QUESTION?
>> Greg: NOTHING.
I JUST WANTED TO SAY HI.
THEY TOLD ME TO BE FAST BUT
APPARENTLY THEY SCREWED IT UP.
>> Emily: I’M REALLY SORRY.
I THINK EVERYONE UNDERESTIMATES
THE POWER OF THE AUTONOMY OF
EVERY INDIVIDUALS MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISION AND THAT’S WHY I AM SO
PROUD AND HONORED TO WORK HERE.
WE CONVEY EVERYTHING SO THAT THE
VIEWER CAN MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS.
A COUPLE IS AGO -- DECADES AGO I
WOULD COMMUTE ON A FAIRY AND I
WOULD READ THE PAPER AND IT WAS
SO ONE-SIDED.
IT DISGUSTED ME.
I STOPPED READING IT AND I SORT
OF HAD A SUSPICION ABOUT THEM.
IT WAS I WHO MADE THAT DECISION,
THE REST OF THE MEDIA ISN’T
GIVEN THEIR VIEWERS OR LISTENERS
OF CHOICE.
>> Greg: JESSE, ONE THING I
LIKE ABOUT YOU IS YOUR ABILITY
FOR SELF REFLECTION.
WHY IS IT MISSING IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE MEDIA?
>> Jesse: I DON’T KNOW.
IF I KNEW, I WOULD TELL YOU.
I DON’T HAVE THAT TYPE OF
ABILITY.
DID EMILY JUST SAYING SHE READS
A PERIODICAL ON A THEORY TO A
METROPOLIS?
>> Emily: I SET A COUPLE
DECADES AGO.
>> Jesse: OKAY.
ALSO GREG BEFORE I SAY
SOMETHING, WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
YOU MET CUOMO AT A BAR OR
SOMETHING.
HOW DO YOU THINK THAT WOULD GO
BETWEEN YOU?
>> Greg: I DON’T KNOW.
I HAVE A FEELING WE DON’T GO TO
THE SAME BARS.
SEE 60 YEAH.
YEAH.
MAY BE BUT IF YOU DID, I HAVE A
FEELING IT MIGHT NOT GO SO WELL
FOR YOU.
THE ONLY SERIOUS POINT I HAVE
FOR YOU IS THIS.
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT BROUGHT US
RUSSIA COLLUSION ARE NOW TELLING
US OBAMAGATE IS A CONSPIRACY.
THE MEDIA, THEY DON’T CARE.
THEY GET IT ALL WRONG.
EVERYTHING THEY SAY IS USUALLY
THE OPPOSITE.
IF THEY SAY THAT THE OBAMA
SPYGATE THING WAS DOWN BY THE
BOOKS, YOU KNOW IT WAS DIRTY AS
SIN.
THAT’S ALL I HAVE TO SAY.
>> Greg: DANA, I HAVE A THEORY
THAT DIVISION IS THE
HAMBURGER HELPER OF CNN.
THEY TAKE A STORY, FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DIVIDE AND THAT MAKES THE
STORY BIGGER.
IT IS THEIR HAMBURGER HELPER.
>> Dana: I LOVED A
HAMBURGER HELPER.
48% OF PEOPLE HAVE A GREAT DEAL
OR FAIR AMOUNT OF TRUST IN THE
MEDIA.
MAYBE THAT IS SOMETHING TO LOOK
AT IN TERMS OF THE POLARIZATION
THAT WE HAVE, NOT EXACTLY SURE
BUT I DO THINK IT’S QUITE RICH
THAT SOMEBODY WHO IS RECOVERING
FROM CORONAVIRUS WENT ON FERRIS
BUELLER’S DAY OFF AND THEN
PRETENDED THAT HE DIDN’T AND
THEN STAGED HIS REEMERGENCE FROM
THE BASEMENT AFTER HE RECOVERED
FROM CORONAVIRUS.
>> Greg: THAT IS A CLASSIC
THAT WILL LIVE FOREVER.
JUAN, LAST WORD.
>> Juan: HOW CAN I ARGUE WITH
YOU?
I WAS TAKEN BY WHAT YOU SAID
BECAUSE YOU SAID AS DANA POINTS
ABOUT HALF OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE DO HAVE SOME OR A HIGH
DEGREE OF CONFIDENCE IN THE
MEDIA.
BUT FEWER HAVE CONFIDENCE IN OUR
POLITICIANS AND I THINK THAT
POLLS SHOW EVEN ON THE
CORONAVIRUS AGAIN, ABOUT 50% OF
AMERICANS TRUST THE MEDIA BUT
ONLY 35% TRUST THE PRESIDENT.
SO YOU COULD PLAY IT EITHER WAY.
YOU WISH WE COULD HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN ALL BECAUSE I WANT
EMILY TO BE ABLE TO READ HER